uh welcome to Hannity thank you for
being with us tonight fighting just
unveiled a bold strategy for 2024. let's
hide in the basement and repeat 2020 all
over again the media they won't care and
with RFK Jr however surging in the
Democratic primary is Biden in trouble
we have details tonight also trouble in
Russia for Vladimir Putin we're going to
analyze this weekend's deadly coup
attempt and why some are skeptical it
even was a coup attempt well both sides
of that debate but first this is what we
can tell you this Monday night about
your government today your government is
corrupt the doj is corrupt and it has
been weaponized your FBI hierarchy is
corrupt and it has been weaponized no
one is above the law unless of course
you're a prominent Democrat especially
with the last name Clinton or Biden now
despite evidence of let's see bribery
felony tax evasion money laundering
racketeering Fair violations
prostitution drug use felony gun on
violation and brandishing Hunters of
free men and will be and his father the
big guy is facing no consequences at all
whatsoever and now they're rubbing it
all in your faces because on Friday
night there's Hunter celebrating a
sweetheart plea deal his little slap on
the wrist in style attending a state
dinner with his father an attorney
general Merrick Garland how convenient a
short time later Joey and Hunter they
all jetted off to Camp David together
how nice that a beautiful weekend
retreat laughing smiling the entire way
this after a newly released text
provided more evidence that pops
allegedly may have been a very integral
part of his son's sketchy overseas
business deals in the Biden family
Syndicate in July 2017 Hunter berated a
Chinese National why for not fulfilling
a commitment quote I am sitting here my
father would like to understand why the
commitment has not been been fulfilled
then Hunter continuing quote I will make
certain that between that man sitting
next to me and every person he knows and
my ability to hold a grudge that you
will not regret that you will regret
rather than following my direction I am
sitting here waiting for the call with
my father well that either sounds like a
Shakedown or Hunter's best invitation of
a mob boss uh I'm Vito Corleone and if
anything should happen to my son Hunter
okay uh using the big guy and all the
big guys friends has leveraged a little
scary of course the White House they
deny Biden's involvement in any and all
of Hunter's deals and Hunters lawyers
they want to know uh that he was really
really high on crack when he sent that
text but Joe seems to think it's one big
joke take a look
I started off without you
and I sold a lot of State secrets and a
lot of very important things we've
shared
oh just so we're clear as documented in
a 2020 1023 form Joe Biden he was
accused by a trusted and well-paid FBI
uh source of taking foreign bribes from
a Ukrainian foreign National in exchange
for policy decisions when he was vice
president remember that was the real
quid pro quo to fire the Ukrainian
prosecutor using a billion of your
taxpayer dollars as leverage you
remember the guy investigating zero
experience Hunter was fired in six hours
so Hunter can continue to get paid uh no
experience at all what a great country
what a great life that's the VP now
there was even a big payoff we're now
told did it happen did they have an even
bigger payoff that we had not known
about we need answers a few months
earlier in late 2019 the FBI apparently
verified Hunter's laptop from hell with
messages that outlined 10 percent for
the big guy and complaints from Hunter
that pops you know had to take and was
taken in half of his income and that he
was forced to pay for pops home repairs
and living expenses and prior to 2019 a
wave of Hard Evidence including photos
that Biden met with more than a dozen of
hunters Farm business partners the very
thing he said he never did well then
there's that July 2017 Shakedown where
Hunter implicated his own father in a
scheme to charge a Chinese foreign
National for access to the big guy then
to top it all off bombshell new
allegations from not one but two IRS
whistleblowers that thought Democrats in
the media love whistleblowers not
anymore apparently who claimed that Joe
and Hunter were protected by Merrick
Garland and Hunter and Joe Biden's doj
and according to those allegations Biden
appointed U.S attorneys they blocked
felony tax charges against Hunter for
years prior to the two that they got him
on only misdemeanor accounts no jail
time one whistleblower Gary shapely
identified four Witnesses who observed
this obstruction and meanwhile Hunter's
map top from hell was buried and
investigators they weren't even allowed
to access it wow it seems like they were
digging hard for justice here and
according to these same whistleblowers
any investigation into the big guy that
was stopped that was stymied but
apparently no one at the White House or
the doj or the state department or the
FBI feels any need to respond in any
serious way to what a real shocking
allegations and last week Barrett
Garland even suggested that any
criticism of the doj is an attack on
democracy and on Friday Clean
Jean-Pierre did her very best to dodge
every single question take a look not a
reasonable question to ask in the past
United States was involved as this
message seems to suggest in some sort of
a coercive conversation for business
dealing by Asana is that something if he
wasn't then maybe you should tell us so
here's the thing and I appreciate the
question I believe my colleague at the
White House Council has answered this
question already yes or no was the
president involved
I just answered the question I just said
I just this is it's not up to you how I
answer the question I just answered the
question you've stated
the president stands by his comment from
the 2020 campaign that he never once
discussed his son's overseas business
dealings with his son and you stood at
that Podium and you reaffirmed that do
you stand by your reaction what I will
say is nothing has changed nothing has
changed and I will leave it there
she answers the question by not
answering the question Biden meanwhile
he just continues to flat out live right
through his teeth or dentures take a
look
no
[Music]
now that's just blatant BS it makes you
wonder what else Biden is lying about
sadly it doesn't matter because Mary
Garland has his back the Democrats at
the doj will never ever seriously
investigate Joe or Hunter they will only
protect him like they protected Hillary
what did I say at the beginning of this
monologue your government is corrupt the
Department of Justice is corrupt and
weaponized as is the FBI hierarchy the
top Democrats working at the FBI and
their Washington field office are only
interested in persecuting any and all
things Donald Trump that's it we saw
this in the 2016 election no reasonable
prosecutor would ever charge Hillary
Clinton while Donald Trump faced a
years-long Witch Hunt because of her
hoax
resulting from her dirty Russian dossier
that she paid for and never mind the 33
000 deleted emails with bleach bid and
of course the vice is destroyed with
hammers we saw it again in 2020 FBI
debunking Hunter's laptop from Hell 2023
looks like we're going to see it all
over again the movie repeats itself
bribery corruption allegations against
the big guy Joe Biden himself swept
under the rug and as for the Democracy
dies in darkness crowd that is the
medium mob that is supposed to speak
truth truth to power the ones that lied
about Russia collusion for three long
years that are on the air right now
lying tonight well they could care less
the country is in serious trouble it
will only get worse if your big guy wins
reelection hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else